herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
sicherlich könnt ihr beim instagram
entdecken und ich habe mich auch mal
wieder herumgetrieben und hab so ein
mega komisches foto gesehen und auf
diesem foto war ein auto so ein ganz
normaler kleinwagen aber er hat auf
einem straßenschild gesteckt zum mega
komisch und ich habe mich gefragt wie
konnte das passieren
und da haben sie überlegten hat mich zu
erinnern ok warten dürfte auch öfters
schon mal solche bilder gesehen so
einfach so unerklärliche dinge drauf
sehen und dann habe ich ein bisschen im
internet um gesuchten hat herausgefunden
wenn man vdz hätten also wie ist das
passiert bei der google bildersuche ein
gibt nur solche bilder kommen ich dachte
mir wir gucken uns einfach mal zusammen
paar an und wir überlegen uns wie die
sachen passiert sind und warum legen wir
also wir gehen einfach mal auf google
google einfach auch besucher stellen und
dann eine eingeben
bild apple und dann lehnt die seife und
ein haufen mega komischer bilder da ich
würde seine gene hätten auch einmal der
reihe nach ein paar durch und legen
direkt mit dem allerersten was zur hölle
was also wenn ich das richtig erkennen
dass ich die zwei rolltreppen jede menge
wasser und bei dem echt sein was das
ganze ein bisschen authentisch wirken
weiß ich dass er mitte unter zwei
mitarbeiter so in diesen uniformen
stehen die leicht ist das irgendwie so
wörz oder irgendwie so ein wasserpark
umsonst oder ss aquarium gebrochen oder
sowas aber das könnte ich mir nicht
vorstellen mega verrückt auf jeden fall
vielleicht ist es auch fähig ich weiß es
nicht genau
wir gucken mal andere alte schwede die
firma mega bitte wo ist das gefühl wenn
ihr eure hand oder irgendwo durch steckt
und dann beim zurückziehen irgendwie
euer handballen oder sowas so
blockierten tätig schon sofort einig
dass nicht mehr zurückziehen können
genau wie fühlt ich werde mir dieses
bild anschauen also dieser mann auf
einem kinderspielplatz und hat irgendwie
geschafft in dieses kinderspital
reinzukommen wenn mir vorstellen
versicherte seine situation handeln
würde ich würde irgendwie probieren
meine beine kaputt machen aber sogar die
beine sind am boden also werde einfach
drin gefangen ich bin irgendwie klaushof
oder sowas aber das ist echt richtig
unangenehm anzusehen
sofort total dem wegen dem ich überhaupt
das ganze video machen
dem dhb und zwar für dieses auto was
einfach in einem hausdach steckt das
auto steckt ihnen haus da also das würde
ich wenn überhaupt bei gta schaffen aber
welcher mensch schafft ein hausdach was
die situation zumindest drei vier meter
höhe
wer schafft es sein auto dar einzupacken
ich hab gleich zu einem ähnlichen fall
eine dokumentation über den vorjahren
aber ich glaube da war das dort für die
über den bordstein leicht abgehoben in
den graben rein und dann würde das
quasi- hoch katapultiert und ist in
diesem dach gelandet
das ist einfach unvorstellbar wem auch
immer das papier ist und wie auch immer
das passiert ist unglaublich so bitter
wenn du einfach keine ahnung betrunken
auto fährt dann will man stellte fest
welche eigentlich sind wir bei
dachziegeln waffe genau ich bin im dach
gelandet so läuft nächste foto-dienst
foto ist weniger verrückt und
unglaubwürdig sag ich mal etwas erste
ding mit den haien aber man fragt sie
einfach so wie konnte das passieren und
zwar als sie den tod von einem baum und
um den baum ist ein autoreifen den man
niemals hätte drauf machen können
niemand hätte irgendwie schaffen können
diesen ausreichend darüber zu ziehen ist
kann keiner erzählt also entweder der
baum ist gewachsen und dieser autoreifen
bei die ganze zeit da weg aus der bauern
fall die durch den autoreifen gewachsen
weil der baum sieht so aus als werde
schon ein paar jahrzehnte alt auf jeden
fall
oder aber er ist irgendwie so auf der
anderen seite aufgeschnitten und wieder
zusammen getackert oder sowas aber warum
sollte das jemand machen also ich weiß
mich wenn ihr irgendwelche theorien oder
erklärungen habt sowas wie diese bilder
entstanden sind und warum passiert was
auf den bildern passiert dann schreib
mir das auf jeden fall mal die
kommentare das nächste fotos werden
heißt zeige ich euch mal die rechte
bildhälfte nur es einfach eine kuh auf
einer weide was glaubt ihr könnt auf der
linken bildhälfte zu sehen sein okay
überlegt noch ein bisschen zeit ja
selbstverständlich ist es eine kuh die
ihren kopf in einem kinderspielzeug auto
hat wie kommt ihres auto auf die beine
und po hat die kuh ihr kopf drin
und warum trägt die kuh das ding mit
sich herum
oha als ob die kraft darstellen leute
gebt euch mal bitte dieses foto hier das
ist einfach eine straßenwalze eine
gottverdammte straten weite diese dinger
wiegen zig tonnen und willig auf dem
rücken
das ding ist nicht irgendwie einen berg
oder sowas wurde das ding hätte umfallen
können und es ist einfach auf der straße
neben der straße
das sieht einfach für die straßenwalze
spontanen müde geworden wenn sie
entschieden so eine pause vom besten zu
machen aber ohne spaß also man bräuchte
wahrscheinlich mit kran wenn denn
überhaupt dieses ding umzuwerfen
ich habe absolut keine ahnung wie das
ding umfallen könnte weil ich meine dass
irgendwie auch der sinn der behauptet
etappen wie es passiert man hat einfach
keine ahnung wie also ich habe irgendwie
das gefühl ist diese fotos vor allem bei
unfällen entstehen weil ich denke mal
wenn man mit hoher geschwindigkeit
unterwegs ist einen unfall baut dann
wird halt jede menge energie da um das
auto in komische orte zu bringen so auch
bei diesem lastwagen hier bist einfach
wie im zeichentrickfilm wo der lastwagen
unseren baum fliegt unter oben drin
hängen bleibt es steckt einfach mit den
vorderrädern und der führerkabine vorne
im st aber die beiden etappen dieser
container sind einfach in einem baum und
ich meine es nicht eine strafe auf dem
bild zu sehen
okay leute diese art von strafen künftig
ihr bestimmt auch uns versichert dass
diese leute die diese entscheiden nur
mit der hand auf sein stab lehnen und in
der luft schweben da ist es anscheinend
das habe ich irgendwo auch mal gehört
dass diesem antrag gestellt in diesem
fall zum beispiel eine platte ist unter
dem teppich damit in die fussstapfen
metallstange und die metallstange führt
quasi unter dem arm von dem typen auch
so ein stuhl auf dem er diese da habe
ich etwa dem keine erklärung ich habe
mich auf jeden fall als kind welches
geben
ich habe mich dumm und dämlich gewundert
wie das funktioniert aber bei mir kriegt
ihr die antwort es ist lange schon als
besitzer foto was irgendwie mit dem
verkehr zu tun hat aber guckt euch das
bitte einfach es ist mit lkw der mitten
auf einer wiese senkrechte dort steht
also dieses votum muss auf jeden fall
ein fake sein weil es einfach nicht
gm würde oder aber das steht ja so
richtig fett drauf oklahoma truck supply
das ist quasi so eine werbetafel von dem
lkw verkäufe für dieses marketing auf
jeden fall zwei daumen hoch
wenn ihr dieses video gerade mögt ihr
gebt ihm noch auch einen daumen hoch
navi wehrstedt okay leute ich glaube
dieses foto ist ein gutes und das
heutige video zu beenden das einfach ein
fahrrad was zwischen zwei häusern auf
einem seil hängt und oben drüber steht
das wort
das war meine frage im heutigen video
also wenn ich mich irgendetwas erklären
können oder selbst über die geschichte
wird hinter einem der bilder die ich
euch gezeigt habe seit ihm eine
kommentare für mich sehr interessieren
ansonsten würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
lasst euch befreien hat und sehen wir im
nächsten video wieder und bis dahin kühl